hello everyone this next game was played
in 1973 it was the intra zonal
tournament in petrópolis Brazil and the
top three contenders of this tournament
would qualify to play in the candidates
tournament and in this game Thomas
brushin is playing against human value
boy which assumed earlier which was the
number three player in the world at the
time this game was played and the reason
I decided to show you this game is that
well
Brunson was extremely cheeky this game
and he decided to let the boy play a
line in the eloquent defense in which he
is famous the way which was considered
to be the strongest player in the world
in this line of the eloquent defense and
one other reason I decided sure this
game back in 2010 my my chess team and
myself we were playing the Croatian team
championship and well a friend of mine
was playing against a strong
international master he had the black
pieces and after the game the
international master won the game and he
told him that while that Ella kind
offense you chose to play isn't a very
popular ever since the game Braunstein
versus to voyage in 1973 and my friend
never saw this game actually and well
you should definitely see this game if
you're an eloquent defense player so
something like this doesn't happen to
you so let's see the game that is one
item is white and blue bond the lube oil
which is black and we have a four by
Bronstein we have a knight to f6 the
other kind defense b5 95 d4 we have d6
now C for kicking tonight and this c4
move this is a this is what the boy
which was famous for playing or with the
black pieces
so he goes nice to b6 and the branch and
plays F for the four point attack of the
other kind defense we have D captures
only five F captors on e5 and now you
voyage plays c5 and we have D 5 by
Bronstein this is a kind of advancing
the pawns a bit too much but what branch
then decided to do it so boyish plays a
six we have a nice to see three now each
chapter 75 seek after 75 and now c4 and
I'll just see four point is very nicely
defended by the night MV 6 and it's kind
of preventing this Bishop from
developing the life
bishop so we have nice to f3 we have the
Bishop to g4 attacking the knight and
now personal place Queen to d4 with this
small queen city for he is attacking
this c4 pawn twice and also the bishop
and g4 so new boy which captures the
knight Bishop captures on f3 we have G
captures on s3 and now Bishop to b4 and
the branch and captures Bishop captures
on c4 the early voltage castles we have
a rose to g1 and this rope that you
wanna move is the idea that Bronstein
decided to use this game you'll see why
so you buy which plays g6 just
preventing any ecig 5 years we have
Bishop to g5 we have Queen to c7 and
this is the branch ends idea by playing
Bishop g5 he allows Queen to c7 and this
Queen to c7 move is now attacking this
bishop on c4 twice and the black would
really love to exchange this bishop but
an even greater threat if the bishop is
defenders are moved its Bishop to c5
pinning the Queen and the rook but
exactly this is a nonsense idea
he plays Bishop to b3 and he invites
refurbish to play Bishop to c5 so we
have Bishop to c5 by the boiler which
and now Queen to f4 so you were which of
course captures the rook and now branch
9 plays d6 attacking the Queen so we
have Queen to c8 and now King to e2 well
Bronstein wanted to bring the rook into
the game of course but he didn't want to
do a queenside castle because this would
put the King on c1 in lines of in line
of avoid screen so he decided to plank
the plan was like King g2 and the world
the worry chère to find a solution over
the board for this move and well like is
actually better here if the voice had
found this Queen to c5 move then he
would be much better in this game and
probably he probably wouldn't lose this
but he played Bishop to c5 and brushing
immediately plays Knight to e4 so we
have nice to d7 and now rook the c1
pinning that bishop
so we have a queen to c6 and now
Bronstein has another great idea people
is rook captures and c5 and by
eliminating this Bishop blacks control
of the dark squares or near the king is
completely shattered
so all the dark squares now belong to
the bro understand
he plays nice captures on c5 and we have
Knight to f6 check so King to h8 and now
Queen to h4 threatening checkmate on h7
we have Quinta b5 check and now Broxton
place King to e3 a very nice move
preventing the black firm from doing any
more checks the voyage plays h5 and here
Bronstein has the continued attacks okay
just place for Knight captures on h5 and
the knight can be captured because it's
instant checkmate and well it's a revive
she has to find find a move and there
really isn't any move to play you might
think that the White King is vulnerable
here or here because these Knights are
very close and the Queen is here and
well you don't have this check on d3 but
let's see what happens is going to d3
displayed if Queen to d3 then simply
came to f2 you get nicely for check
because well there aren't any more
checks in the position so you just have
to play something like 90 for sacrifice
and ice and their captors on e4 and the
Queen's the d4 check King to g2 Queen
capture some B to check in King to h3
and there are no more checks and the
nice statistics check with mate is
coming so after 92 h5 your voyage is
pretty much forced to play Queen
captures on b3 woods check so we have a
capture some b3 and now nice to d5
checked and the Bronstein attacks with
his King he plays King to d4 and one of
the Knights is definitely going to be
captured so he he plays a knight c6
check bringing the King deeper Bronston
casters can capture some d5 and now
Knight get person g5 and Boston doesn't
capture the night first he plays a
Knight to f6 check with from the Queen
and the knight can't cover up because
the Queen can capture it so we have a
to g7 and now between Jefferson g5 and
now well Bronstein is a lot better here
but we've always tried a couple of more
moves he tries a rock to d8 we have six
F captors and six kings captures on e6
and the king is coming to help with the
attack we have a rope to f8 d7 and now F
I try the bow which tries to go for the
King using a six and here branch and
decides to give up his Queen but this is
all over so we had roughly six checks
King King t5 another rope the f5 we're
painting the kingdom Queens so we have
Queen captures pawn captures and now
branch and promote respond to a queen on
d8 we have F captors on g4 Queen to d7
check King 36 now grabbing the pole and
b7 we have roped the rope to g6 and now
F 4 and in this position well the world
is resigned and there was no more hope
for him to to win the intra zonal or
even to qualify in the top three places
to go to the candidate and I think it
was yeah and we can making one this
tournament with effing Geller to follow
and so on so definitely a beautiful game
by Bronstein it's all I mean almost an
immortal game playing again like this
against the world number three in a line
that he is known to be an expert in I
mean this was like I said very cheeky
from brunch time and I did show you that
game whereas possibly crushed bronze and
in that Kings gambit so I wanted to show
a nice game where branch and delivers a
brilliancy against the world number
three so yeah that the game I do hope
you enjoyed it as usual you can check
two of my previous videos here as usual
thanks to everyone who continues
contributing to my channel in any way
whatsoever
and this is thank you for watching and I
will see you soon